already one move on the board and I
think that gives us a clue Magnus has
gone back to his childhood favorite one
E4 he's played this throughout his
career and in situations where he wants
to draw I'm recalling the final game of
the 2016 world championship against
kyrieking he forced to draw very quickly
in the Berlin
um he always seems to go back to this
opening 1e4 because there are forcing
variations there are forcing ways that
you can kind of guarantee you get a
stable position and also flashback to
one of his world championship matches
against Anand where it was the Sicilian
and he found a way to shut down anan's
activity
um so I think that's the name of the
game for the experienced Magnus Carlton
to shut down La Majora's fun and it is
the Sicilian good choice in a must win
situation for black and he just plays
like this he plays the open Sicilian he
gets a comfortable position and everyone
is just struggling against him and wow I
was about to praise Magnus for being
Universal but Mama jarov pushing Gary
the G Pawn forward two squares you'll
never see this in a serious game from
top players he's just forgetting peace
development he's throwing his pawns
forward he's trying to kick away White's
night with this Pawn it's obviously not
a good move because you have to develop
your pieces but he's already trying to
shock Magnus playing on that
psychological Factor
um this game is not going to be calm no
matter what Magnus tries to do even if
Magnus tries to shut it down okay
stopping the advance of blacks porn now
manager of he's just determined he's
shown us with that move he just wants to
go down in style and uh okay now we will
see an open Sicilian but what is Black's
Pawn doing on G5 it's so weak you could
even take it now to your van codes
this is chess humor
it's just the desperation from Shaq you
know do not do this at home I mean as
David's mentioned you know the G5 Pawn
is weak and uh Magnus is just say hey
I'm gonna play it like a normal game and
uh I'm constantly gonna ask you why did
you put your Pawn on that square I have
six moves six moves so he's freestyling
as you mentioned that word desperation
Ivanka maybe it's not showing enough
self-belief from Shaq that he has to
Freestyle like this but uh we also have
to commend him because he's entertaining
us showing us something we've never seen
before
um someone who passed away recently Mike
Bassman a very influential International
master from the UK and he used to like
to start games with the creepy crawly
opening as we call it
there are reasons you play it and that's
mostly psychological the opponent wants
to punish you and therefore they get too
carried away and they lose their
objectivity but Magnus it's going to be
hard to unsettle him and this is the
downside of pushing your Jeep one too
far forward white is gonna push and
undermine your Pawn structure White's
Rook on the edge file about to get open
or he can move his Knight but that's not
great either
yeah he does take this Pawn but even if
Magnus doesn't go and capture this Pawn
with his Rook right now which okay he
has just done but even if he hadn't
Black's Pawn structure is ruined it's
wrecked can you imagine anywhere for the
black king to be safe
I think you have to stay in the center
because the black king is definitely not
going to the right anymore it's too open
over there White's Rook is ready uh for
an attack you definitely can't go to the
left side of the board you've got too
many pieces in the way you can't Castle
on that side either
um so Black's King is an eternal
I mean it's it's an eternal Target for
white yeah and oh actually she doesn't
doesn't even bother just uh keep it
simple and then the White's King is
getting ready to Castle the pawn is
under Fire yeah this position is so ugly
and uh poor Mama jarov impressing us so
much with that g Pawn push but uh this
is the reason we don't freestyle in the
opening the consequence is you might get
a position full of holes and okay the
Knight moves to attack this Rook but the
Rook is just gonna shift you can step up
one square it can just step back the
whole way if you want to play it super
safe if you just play it safe Retreat
The Rook okay he does blockade in the
end Magnus Carson but yeah next move
pretty much automatically you Castle
Queen side
okay he doesn't first he moves his
Bishop but he's getting ready to Castle
queenside Magnus and when that does
happen that will signal the beginning of
the end potentially for Mama Jara for
the Knight firstly attacks the white
Rook okay he's found a good formation
we've got to give him credit
uh The Rook is going to be forced to
retreat
and uh okay there we go it Retreats a
bit of an odd Square in the eye line of
this bishop that's unexpected I mean of
course white is still massively better I
was gonna say go all the way to the
starting Square yeah I mean this Square
just looks vulnerable it's as if you're
giving manager of Hope somehow but yeah
if you push this Pawn forward to attack
this rook and attack the knight at the
same time white can defend that uh those
two threats in a very simple way White's
Knight can jump to block and this would
be very strong a capture does not help
black at all because actually white
would have full control over the light
squares instead manager of jumps out
with his Queen to one side of the board
but Magnus I mean he wants to Castle
anyway
watch King is going to be super safe on
the B1 Square
is manager of do you think Ivanka really
gonna try and copycat and Castle well he
would dream of her I mean that's just
I just act like a pipe dream or just
some ambition because as Magnus has done
just Retreat the night and the pawn on
D6 is hanging yeah I think we might see
this game finish quite soon
unfortunately for mamajaro if the queen
is hanging you have to move her no
matter where you go if Magnus wants to
keep it super safe he takes this Pawn
gets the Queen's off the board clear
Pawn advantage or you can even take this
Pawn remember this one is still hanging
it's attacked three times okay manager
puts his Queen in the middle of the
board but is this queen just gonna get
trapped at some point uh I guess his
idea if the white porn steps forward to
attack the queen which it has just done
is to give up his Knight but you're
gonna be a whole piece down and we see
the black queen trapped it's captured
the White Queen is captured but at the
end Magnus just wins a night for free
and Shaq has decided he's had enough of
that and Magnus takes the point wow that
was a quick game a quick day three games
Magnus wins them all